what's going on guys you are here for a
momentous occasion
so we had a previous episode where we
decided what the best 80s action movie
of all time was well we are back to
decide what the best 90s action movie is
and we have an awesome panel to help us
out he's one of the foremost movie
reviewers on the worldwide Internet
crisp stuckman thank you very much man I
really appreciate it he's an old pal of
the show we're glad to have him back
he's one of the schmoes no he's a very
funny stand-up comedian let's welcome
back Mark Ellis and you how like my mom
always said always bet on black he's a
force of nature Nick Monday okay way to
win so we're continuing with the same
rules we used in our 80s action bracket
the movie has to include a terrorist
drug dealer buddy cop Stallone or
Schwarzenegger but for the 90s we're
expanding the rules if a film is
produced or directed or made by Jerry
Bruckheimer or Michael Bay if it has one
of these three actors Steven Seagal
jean-claude Van Damme or Jana Reeves BAM
it's a nineties action movie we spent a
lot of time deciding what movies were
going to be in here and then we used the
scientific method of IMDB rating to rank
them and establish the matchups are you
guys mega pumped yeah only I am to the
first match of Timecop against number
one seed the matrix
Nik Mundi let's go down on the end and
start with you sir we got an upset
Timecop is legitimately the best time
travel movie in the 90s
it's Jean Claude Van Dam's best movie
and you got rod silver and it's [ __ ]
awesome BAM that's 104 Timecop let's
come back around a stuckman I don't
agree with you at all the matrix my
opinion is I'm much better and much more
influential action movie than time cup
ever was stuckman not sit up at 1-1
Ellis I love that it comes down to me
because Chris I respect your opinion on
most things you can have your red pill
my friend me and Nick money you're
taking the whole milk on top because
Timecop is beating the matron Timecop is
a better movie than the major
not just because of the splits on the
countertop because Van Dam's bosses DJ
from Animal House this is unprecedented
the 16 seed Timecop knocking off the one
seed the matrix Timecop moving on well
let's see if he can recover from that
beatdown coz Keano is back Point Break
going against True Lies damn it Ellis
Point Break is the reason why we have
great films today like The Hurt Locker
and legs zero dark thirty because
Kathryn Bigelow directed Point Break he
got her her start it put the tum 250
year storm into the lexicon Point Break
is gonna upset true eyes Mundi damn it
a screen junkies first we have shut up
Nick Mundy here's the thing about True
Lies and I was gonna save this for later
on because I thought it was gonna go but
I gotta bring out the big guns
yeah True Lies is James Cameron and
Arnold Schwarzenegger special movie I
think it's my favorite 90s action movie
Point Break is awesome
I gotta go true lives one-one and you
just reminded us this is a James Cameron
Kathryn Bigelow up smackdown not since
they were both nominated for Best
Director and married okay it's one-one
stuckman Point Break
has an FB i-- agent I am an FBI agent
Point Break of course is a better action
movie than True Lies I'm sorry it just
is yom-yom eternal to the one a goddamn
oz Nick shut it down Point Break moving
on maybe right now Schwarzenegger can
redeem himself as number four seed Total
Recall takes on demolition man stuckman
talk to us Total Recall is one of the
best sci-fi action movies ever made
Total Recall
absolutely Ellis Total Recall has a
chick with three boobs in it meanwhile
demolition man has sex with Sandra
Bullock where you never even get to
touch her despite the fact that I love
the concept of all restaurants being
Taco Bell I gotta go with Total Recall
Total Recall takes it moving on
bad boys versus the rock at number five
Wow
I don't think Nick's enjoying this
experience is hard and it sure is hard
you know what your vote didn't matter
the last round so I'm coming to you
first I love bad boys the bad boys too
is the bad boys I love the most
it's a 2000 movie that would win mm the
rock is why I still give Michael Bay
like credit it's my second it's an
amazing movie boom one oh the rock
Ellis bad boys bad boys what you gonna
do what you gonna do when Sean Connery
welcomes you to the rock the rock takes
it maybe my favorite movie of all time
ever besides anything it's the round a
time boom that means the rock is moving
on here's another it's nonstop
barnburners you guys Terminator 2
against number 15 Steven Seagal's under
siege haha Terminator 2 all the way Nick
mundi German agent that means Terminator
2 is moving on Ellis what's that is that
I've probably seen under siege more than
I've seen Terminator 2 but obviously
Terminator 2 will say hasta LaVista to
Steven Seagal's best work the ten seat
against the seven seat last Boy Scout
against number seven speed Ellis talk to
you know the song sing with me Friday
night it's a great night for football
okay I guess I was the only one who
remembered the opening of the Last Boy
Scout it's a really fun baby that was
really as I climax the fact that spoiler
Damon Wayans saves the day by throwing a
football on a horse from the field up to
the skybox
I gotta give it to speed it's a really
well put together rash movie and it
expanded can Teresa's career Chris
Stockman no no do me first okay Mundy
look I respect you but last Boy Scout is
the second best i heart ever less Boy
Scout should win this thing last Boy
Scouts boom one-one Chris Stockman speed
a hundred percent boom speed moving on
Nick Mundy all right P next matchup die
hard with a vengeance up against our
number fourteen film Air Force One
start with stuckman die hard with a
vengeance at times competes with die
hard for me to this day I will watch
that movie and actually start to
perspire like it will make me sweat
because you just feel the summer heat of
that movie turn on the AC
die hard with a vengeance one oh thank
you sir Mark Ellis
I saw die hard with a vengeance twice
opening
a I stand by my decision I wish I had
time to see the third time then that day
for the three-peat die hard with a
vengeance takes it this last one a
Sophie's Choice right here Conair
against number six face-off oh you man
that's like the best of 97 ah Nick talk
to me I'm gonna go face-off
Wow 100 pesos Thank You Nick Mark Ellis
see I'm going Conair because both of
them have really cockamamie premises but
it's so fun to watch Conair this group
of prisoners led by John Malkovich
Nicolas Cage with the best fake hair
he's ever had almost every time John
Cusack says another one you can hear his
soul dying on-screen I gotta go Connor
one one all comes down to Chris Stockman
I agree with him in regards to the con
air quotes I agree with you in some of
the ways about face off - I mean you got
to have John Travolta go on yeah I'm
good looking like how can you not have
that in a movie it's amazing them wait
you did lick it God that being said
Connor has the best smile and wink to a
camera ever by Nicolas Cage Connor
Stockman give me a Connor stuck
absolutely con air all the way come on
welcome in John Mathis said Connie are
moving on and fun fact John Cusack
refuses to be interviewed about that
movie because he hates it so much don't
blame him so our second round is set
Timecop the number 16 seat that upset
the number one against Point Break let's
start with Mark Ellis look when I was a
kid I was on Team Van Damme my favorite
Van Damme film of all time is hard
target my favorite cannery / Patrick
Swayze / skydiving bank-robbing surfing
movie is Point Break the winner
I'm sorry jean-claude is Point Break
okay Nick Mundi Point Break is is great
it's a great movie I will watch it more
times then I will watch Timecop Point
Break moving on up next Total Recall vs.
The Rock let's make this fast
The Rock is a great action movie it has
Sean Connery in one of his last good
movies Nicolas Cage is fantastic and it
looks amazing it's one of Michael Bay's
best movie but Total Recall for goodness
sakes
Nick Mundy the rock BAM
Mark Ellis the rock
the rock yeah moving I went it one I get
one
oh it's getting personal and it's not
getting any easier Terminator 2 versus
speed Mark Ellis oh looks means a great
movie it's the best die hard ripoff I've
ever seen
but Terminator 2 was a seminal moment in
the history of film you got to go t - t
- Chris Stockman
I agree completely Terminator 2 amazing
amazing science fiction action movie
Terminator 2 moves on Nick thoughts
Terminator 2 and our last matchup of the
second round die hard with a vengeance
vs. Conair Chris Tuchman say the right
answer Chris you know it's the right eye
hard with a vengeance I went on a first
date on Conor and it did not go well
okay so diehard with Benny's die hard
with a vengeance moving on Ellis what
would you have said I took a girl -
neither film and I haven't since die
hard with a vengeance we are down to the
final four Point Break
versus the rock mmm Nick hmm the rock
the rock is gone I I've said this for
are people in the movie The Rock is just
a great phrase and it's a great movie
it's a great person The Rock's going to
win one oh the rock Marc Ellis it's very
hard for you to go against the rock
because I stayed out after curfew to
watch the end of the movie however the
Rocky Michael Bay confidence and we see
what Michael Bay does with confidence
point Brigade kathryn bigelow confidence
would see what she does with that Johnny
Utah's movie Point Break here one one
the rock wanted me to joke we've like
going Alcatraz shut it down shut it down
Chris stuckman Keanu Reeves sky dived
out of an airplane Point Break Point
Break knocks off number five seed the
rock this is why hurry Point Break going
to the finals guys I got to tell you I'm
a little bit flabbergast at that point
break beat Seminole action film the rock
let's just look at the gaggle of
villains in the rock it's a bunch of no
names led by Ed Harris however in Point
Break you have the ex-presidents that's
why it gets the nod the rock has three
generations of heroes Sean Connery 80s
Michael Biehn and 90s Nicholas
arguably the greatest action star in the
90s if your only argument is that
Nicolas Cage was in a lot of action
movies back then and made a lot of money
guess what he still isn't a ton of
action sorry
movies the rock is his best goddamn
movie and it's the best movie of the
nightmare he's not eating on we can talk
about we could have a whole episode
about this but Point Break has made it
to the finals all right Eddie made it to
the finals are you guys happy no one
surfs in that okay where's pink girl
gonna make it guys no one sir Tank Girl
did not make our list if you are upset
about that leave us a comment below
our second Final Four matchup Terminator
2 against die hard with a vengeance
okay look Terminator 2 is such an
incredible movie how many times we're
gonna say it everyone knows it's amazing
die hard with a vengeance though I think
is one of the most underrated action
movies of all time I need like another
medic and I hear their arguments that
okay because I honestly this is like the
hardest decision of my life and I just
got judges yes you can thank you Nick
Mundy look I look I've made a point that
my whole screen junkies career is about
die hard but Terminator 2 like isn't a
it's an amazing movie and it's ready to
show my job as much as I love die hard
none of the sequels or is nearly as good
as dying damn derivative duo no tornade
or two that's how you make a definitive
statement Mark Ellis you could be mine
die hard with a vengeance however it did
not build upon the greatness of the
first two it was merely another good die
hard movie whereas Terminator 2 elevated
the original source material that puts
it over the edge for me
t2 will be battling in the finals t2
moves on Chris what would you have said
Terminator 2 the finals are set Point
Break vs. Terminator 2 time cop um King
time cop Chris Stockman I'm coming to
you first no passing this time no
passing yes look if I said that Point
Break was better than Terminator 2 my
career and my life would be over because
a lot of my friends would probably
murder me in my sleep Terminator 2
Terminator 2 Mark Ellis I'm not gonna
murder you sleep but I'll defend you in
your sleep I'm actually going to take
Point Break over Terminator 2
because Point Break is a better 90s
action film Point Break needed to come
out the 90s it did and it made the 90s
better for all of us thank you the Red
Hot Chili Peppers for making a cameo in
their unbelievable
Chris Stockman walking off the set Point
Break Terminator 2 tied up one one who
could've saw this coming it all comes
down to Nick Mundy Nick it feels like
you've been a little bit bullied
throughout this tournament but now the
power is in your hands how does that
feel yeah well not great because um this
is like my my six favorite going to gets
like my eighth favorite so um but this
is how democracy works I guess so um
look Point Break is a great 90s movie
premiere choose a great movie
there's no qualifier to it it still
holds up its Schwarzenegger second best
move because True Lies should have been
in this conversation well true lie
should have been won but Nick I think
you just undercut everything you style
but hey I won I in the end on one so
where's the prize um Nick you did not
win Terminator 2 has won let's give it a
round of applause BAM this is what we're
talking about Terminator 2 the best 90s
action film of all time or at least the
night how's that toy looks a lot more
like Patrick Swayze that it does Arnold
Schwarzenegger if you are still watching
this and you did not throw your computer
against the wall and anger disgust tell
us what the best 90s action film in your
opinion is leave us a comment in the
section below tell us why best comment
we will send you a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my awesome panel
Chris stuckman thank you for being here
check him out his YouTube channel Chris
stuckman great movie reviews check out
the schmoes know on YouTube and their
podcast Marc Ellis thank you thank you
you can also find me tied up in Nick
Monday's basement and Nick thanks for
having me I'm just glad no one won
Norway's happy leaving today Terminator
2 one thank you for watching
hit me up on Twitter hit them all up on
Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick bye bye
now will do me he didn't fare that well
on this version gaining not only awesome
powers but a horribly disfigured pretty
gross appearance with claws and hooves
kind of like if you imagine Iron Man
mating with a scent or and this is their
baby that also happens to be a homicidal
maniac